(audience applauds)
- So when you were a kid,
what kind of music were you into?
And especially growing up in Egypt,
that had to have a different
kind of influence, right?
- Dude, all my pictures when I was a kid,
I was in the full outfit,
but really I'm trying to
just dance around the fact
of your question of what did
I listen to when I was a kid?
And I'm like, I loved the
boy bands for a little bit.
(audience cheering)
- You did, I loved it, I love that.
- Well, I was in second grade.
- There was some great melodies there.
- For sure, for sure.
They hold up in time.
I was definitely in second grade like,
all right here, just watch me, watch me,
and I'll do like my.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my gosh, I want this footage.
- And then I went to a
Backstreet Boys concert
and I threw up on the first song
because the girls were so loud,
they were screaming so loud.
I don't know how that equaled
out to me throwing up but...
(audience laughs)
- It's overwhelming.
- I know what happened though.
Like they came down on these hover boards
and everyone was going so crazy.
I was going...
(Machine mumbling)
(audience laughs)
- It's a lie.
- And then I left and then
the next concert I returned to
was Destiny's Child.
(audience applauds)
- I love you so much right now.
- Which is why because
Nelly was opening up
and he had this song "Ride
With Me" and when he said,
hey, is it pass me the money
or it must be the money?
- [Clarkson] Must be the money.
- Okay it must be the money.
So when that happened, money with his face
fell from the ceiling.
(Clarkson laughs)
- That's amazing.
- Yeah, and I was with my dad
and my dad was just so lost.
(audience laughs)